[Applaudissements]
bonsoir chers amis vous avez vu des
choses qui sont pas bons exceptionnels
là ce que vous allez voir
sinon je vous en prie on se tait ducale
je n'accepterai pas un mot de votre part
parce que c'est sérieux et ça nécessite
de la concentration a lancé vous paie
votre vie regarde moi je vais mettre
deux directs ont dit voilà il me faut
quelques accessoires alors voici bernard
et des ballons merci zanfrino merci des
rouleaux d'été alors par exemple il me
faut une bouche innocente ça va être dur
ici autour de la table qui arrive in
jabbi dibba ne s'entendait j'avais
service et le simple ballon tu le goff
le reste est ce que quelqu'un d'autre
peut souffler peut-être j'avais demandé
j'avais demandé on ne sait jamais vous
avez donné un peu plus j'avais demandé
petite aiguille évidemment pas fini g
bâle ont peut-être lé ballon oui voilà
comme ça serait plus jeunes allées
dallées ont fait de la télévision a
soulevé dans un ballon ça c'est pour toi
un temps encore alors tu as marck c paix
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le message mais attention l'action se
déroule ici ludivine un petit 9 savais
que j'allais payet j'aime la fureur
encore un peu de ça c'est bon ouais
attendant vous allez voir c'est
impressionnant alors maintenant
attention garde le ballon ferme bleue
c'est très confus comme tout est clair
ils ont donc gonflé de ballons voici une
aiguille ne grande aiguille oui elle est
très grande donc tu vas essayer de le
rentrer dans le ballon il faut rentrer
l'éguille dans le ballon oui et c'est
pour bien montrer que tout va bien j'ai
pris les ballons au hasard
bernard il tombe elle se dote le
préservatif j'espère va pas préfère
justement à lévis plus aux lèves et tu
vois
bravo continue je vais trouver les
façons c'est exposer nos voiles a tenté
et raté
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
jeu mais je crois que j'ai trouvé celui
qui va venir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dja blé et voilà n'oubliez pas vous
pouvez voter avec le hashtag magique et
à gaza est fermé le mais parfois tu sais
pas toi le tout mais l'exploit justement
un exploit c'est loupé attention je
demande le silence un peu de silence
s'il vous plaît à l'auteur pierre
laporte envoyez-les aiguille j'ai
remarqué que les de regarder il ya plus
de ballons les concentrations s'il vous
plaît attention et les aidants est honni
les deux ans et il est enfin faut que je
fasse un peu de salles obscures regard
des éléments de l'anp ouais parce que
vous voyez là l'on sent que la fête a
l'air bien sympa là vous voyez comment
de la première série la voix regardez
j'avais le transpercer allez allez
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas fini je vais le ressortir des
joueurs tous vos regards admiratifs des
[Rires]
yeux et de la force à les coincer la
salle à part
[Applaudissements]
il a été traîné longtemps pour faire ce
tour quelle est sa venue là